Bit Torrent's solution to free-riding is called
choking, which is a type of game theoretic
strategy, called tit for tat. Choking is
a temporary refusal to upload chunks to another
peer that is requesting them. Downloading, of
course, occurs as normal. But if a node
is unable to download from any particular
peer, it simply doesn't upload to that peer.
This ensures that nodes cooperate. And
eliminates the free rider problem. If you're
interested in the game theory behind
why this strategy ensures cooperation, I encourage
you to go read about the
repeated prisoner's dilemma problem. Where, a tit-for-tat
strategy, such as that which is shown
here, ensures cooperation among mutually distrustful parties.